bien des questions et un début de
polémique après le naufrage du moule
whist car vous transporter 450 tonnes de
produits toxiques destinés à l'industrie
nucléaire changements probables à la
tête du groupe peugeot citroën ou jean
paul parayre pourrait céder la place à
jacques calvet dans les semaines qui
viennent presque le calme plat pour les
concurrents de la transat le vent est
brusquement tombée alors que l'arrivée
devrait se jouer dans les prochaines
heures
mesdames messieurs bonsoir yat-il danger
de pollution au large des côtes belges
c'est la question que l'on se pose ce
soir alors que 450 tonnes d'hexafluorure
d'uranium repose par 15 mètres de fond
au large d'ostende c'est la conséquence
du naufrage du cargo français le monde
oui qui transportait dans ses cales 30
conteneurs de ce produit les autorités
belges et françaises se veulent
rassurantes en rappelant que le produit
en question l'hexafluorure d'uranium est
très faiblement radioactifs et que dans
l'hypothèse improbable d'une rupture de
ces conteneurs la pollution serait
négligeable
reste que cette affaire à nîmes la
polémique sur la sécurité qui devrait
entourer les transports de produits
radioactifs polémique d'autant plus vive
que dans un premier temps l'armateur du
cargo français aurait demandé aux marins
de ne pas révéler la nature de leur
cargaison
après le naufrage il a en effet fallu
attendre hier les révélations de
greenpeace et de la cfdt pour connaître
le contenu des cales du navire
je vous propose tout de suite de faire
le point de la situation sur place avec
michelle perrot et henri le mont louis
le voisine
ces images prises il ya quelques mois
dans le port du havre sont probablement
les dernières réalisé avant son naufrage
de mont louis est un cargo roulier est
simplement aider charbonneau rapide de
4200 tonnes de jauge brute destiné à
tout transport de marchandises il a été
construit en 72 pour le compte de la
compagnie générale maritime
un certain mystère demeure toujours
autour des circonstances précises de la
collision
selon le syndicat des marins cfdt le
mato de veille à pied par ses supérieurs
avaient dû quitter son poste pourtant le
maître mécanicien du cargo affirmé que
le lieutenant de pont l'avait alors
remplacé à la barre
à 18 km au large d'ostende l'épave du
mont louis qui repose à 15 mètres de
fond à fleurs à marée basse
un bâtiment de la marine de guerre belge
surveillent la zone de naufrage n'est
interdit à tout navire d'approcher le
départ de navires militaires français le
patrouilleur le glaive
le dragueur hibiscus demeure également à
proximité
ils sont notamment chargés d'effectuer
des prélèvements d'eau de mer afin de
vérifier si celle ci n'est pas pollué
par la cargaison du bateau
les résultats des premières analyses cas
présent sont révélés négatifs
je peux j'ai tout à fait affirmatif
suivant les dernières mesures qui ont
été faites à 11 heures toutes les
mesures sont négatifs
donc il n'y a aucune radiation les
autorités belges réunis en comité de
crise instant n'ont pas accepté que le
consultant consul français assistent à
leur réunion
nous allons de nouveau insisté auprès
des autorités françaises pour qu'ils
nous fournissent toutes les informations
nécessaires concernant les navires qui
sont actuellement sur place
on s'est menti c'est est ce qu'on vient
faire là on veut connaître l'identité de
son avis et la mission qui a été confiée
en plus nous avons insisté auprès d'eux
autour des françaises d'être informés
concernant la cargaison
et puis quelle mesure les entende
concernant le sauvetage de saône à
venise
ce soir on apprend que deux compagnies
étrangères ont été chargés de repousser
des opérations de récupération de la
cargaison dumont lui un délai de deux à
trois semaines seraient nécessaires pour
la récupération l'hexafluorure d'uranium
je vous le disais il ya un instant les
experts français et belges estiment que
les risques de pollution radioactive
sont minimes
dans l'hypothèse où un ou plusieurs des
conteneurs viendrait à s'ouvrir
reste le danger toxiques au cas où le
gaz entrerait en contact avec l'eau les
explications de jacques violet
l'hexafluorure d'uranium est un composé
chimique utilisé dans l'industrie
nucléaire
c'est simplement le minerai d'uranium
naturel mélangé avec du fluor
il s'agit d'un gaz dangereux toxiques
mais très faiblement radioactifs
il est utilisé pour l'enrichissement de
l'uranium destiné aux centrales
nucléaires
cet enrichissement pour le nucléaire
civil est très faible 3% par rapport à
l'enrichissement militaire pour la bombe
atomique qui est lui à plus de 90%
pendant le transport
le produit est stocké dans les
conteneurs véritable carapace d'acier
capable de résister à de très fortes
pressions
les quinze conteneurs du mont louis
seront récupérés pour l'instant il ne
constitue pas un véritable danger
on a parlé beaucoup de radioactivité et
le certain qu'il ya là des produits
radioactifs mais que le danger des
produits qui sont en cause dans cette
affaire est beaucoup plus un danger
chimiques plus classique c'est celui de
la libération des six deux corées à
partir justement du contact éventuel du
produit avec l'eau et accès à ces un
produit qui est toxique et je dirais de
manière beaucoup plus classique comme
produits radioactifs
cette affaire a bien sûr provoqué la
colère des écologistes c'est ainsi que
les verts exigent l'annulation d'un
transport de plutonium qui devrait
prochainement partir de cherbourg en
direction du japon
et puis une autre conséquence directe
celle là du naufrage de samedi un autre
cargo le pacifique fischer qui bat
pavillon britannique et qui transporte
des matières radioactives
ce cargo s'est vu refuser l'autorisation
d'accoster dans les ports de panama
alors qu'il empruntait le canal qui
traverse ce pays et cela pose à nouveau
le problème du transport des produits
radioactifs dont plusieurs millions de
tonnes sont acheminés chaque année
jacques violle le bon road in sur ces
images affecté à la liaison le havre
riga un bateau identique au mont louis
qui a fait naufrage
ces deux bateaux ne sont pas des navires
spécialisés dans le transport des
produits dangereux notamment ce type de
containers ses confrères là sont
toujours embarqué à l'extérieur sur le
pont
à environ 25 mètres du château pour
éviter que de lire des radiations
puissent venir bel appartement de
l'équipage sont pas conçus pour françois
des marchandises dangereuses il ya peu
de bateaux en france dont supporters en
général les bateaux sont compensées des
bâtons qui sont faits ou encore du
matériel roulant dont notamment des
voitures en france chaque année c'est
plus de 1 million de tonnes de matières
radioactives qui circulent par route et
par chemin de fer l'hexafluorure
d'uranium par exemple actuellement dans
les flancs du mont louis a été
transporté par la route depuis
pierrelatte dans la drôme jusqu'au havre
avant d'y être embarqués mais ce sont
les déchets radioactifs qui pose le plus
de problème ils restent dangereux pour
l'homme pendant des dizaines voire des
centaines d'années ils sont transportés
dans de véritables containers blindés
mais si l'industrie nucléaire est la
plus grande productrice de déchets
toxiques
il existe également quelques 2 millions
de tonnes de déchets industriels en tout
genre produit par quelques 500 mille
sociétés peu scrupuleuses les pollueurs
sont nombreux l'industrie chimique la
pharmacie où les fabricants d'acier un
rapport sur le grave problème des
déchets a été remis en juin dernier
madame bouchardeau pour mieux contrôler
mieux transporter mieux stocker les
déchets de notre société de consommation
le cargo français montlouis s'apprêtait
à parier à destination de riga en union
soviétique c'est là qu'il devait livrer
son chargement l'on peut se demander ce
soir georges bortoli pourquoi la france
livre des produits à base d'uranium à
l'union soviétique ou bien des hommes il
s'agit d'un aller retour et que cet
aller-retour se comprend si l'on se
reporte au début des années 70 époque à
laquelle la france ne peut pas encore
produire de l'uranium enrichi nécessaire
pour faire tourner ses centrales
nucléaires
alors où trouver cet uranium enrichi qui
nous manque dans deux pays seulement à
l'époque les états unis et l'urss et la
france normalement décide d'en acheter
aux deux voilà pourquoi depuis 1973 des
matières faiblement radioactive partent
de chez nous pour l'urss et reviennent
après enrichissement reviennent en
france ou bien d'ailleurs puisqu'en
l'occurrence une partie
l'uranium une fois enrichi devait aller
aux centrales nucléaires belges
seulement voilà est-ce que cet
aller-retour reste vraiment utile alors
que maintenant la france a appris à
enrichir l'uranium et même en enrichir
beaucoup alors on se pose la question
est tout naturellement là les derniers
en 83 la france renégocié le contrat qui
la lie à moscou et les soviétiques
disent bon d'accord on traitera moins
chaque année d'uranium français mais à
condition de que le contrat je continue
plus longtemps voilà pourquoi ce contrat
qui je le répète les l'unité d'une
utilité moins évidente qu'avant durera
probablement au delà de l'année 2000
voilà donc ce que l'on pourrait dire ce
soir sur ce dossier qui devrait
connaître d'autres développements dans
les jours qui viennent du remue ménage
en perspective à la tête du groupe
peugeot-citroën l'actuel président du
directoire de ce groupe devrait annoncer
sa démission c'est du moins un point
insistant qui n'a été ni confirmée ni
démentie par la direction
l'actuel président paul parayre céderait
sa place à jacques calvet c'est
l'aboutissement logique d'une situation
qui se développait depuis plusieurs mois
jean claude renoult si sa démission se
confirme en dira de jean paul parayre il
a perdu jacques calvet a gagné peut-être
mais on pourrait dire aussi qu'il pense
sur un succès de taille
c'est en effet à lui que le groupe psa
doit ses deux locomotives actuelle la
205 de peugeot et la bêtise de s'y prête
deux voitures née de la banque d'organes
commun mise en place par jean paul
parayre
mais cette réussite ne dissimule pas les
échecs et notamment l'incapacité à
digérer le rachat de citroën et de
chrysler avec au bout du compte la
déconfiture de talbot et des milliards
de francs de pertes
pire encore le constructeur n'a pas su
adapter ses effectifs
d'où l'arrivée du banquier jacques
calvet il y a deux ans l'ancien
directeur de cabinet de valérie giscard
d'estaing ne connaît pas l'automobile
mais il arrive avec un credo
inébranlable pour assainir les finances
de psa il faut manier le bistouri 7400
suppressions d'emplois chez peugeot
talbot à 83 6 mille chez citroën
un an plus tard et chaque fois jacques
calvet obtient découvert
les deux tiers des licenciements demande
aujourd'hui parce qu'il a su régler le
problème des sureffectifs
il est déjà le numéro un si ça devient
officiel chaque calvet pourra alors
s'attaquer à l'essentiel la création et
la fabrication d automobiles à la
frontière de l'économie et du tourisme
c'est une histoire exemplaire que vous
allez voir maintenant une histoire en
tout cas édifiante au moment où l'on
parle de création d'entreprise et ou
l'attitude des banques et parfois et
même souvent contestées on leur reproche
notamment d'être trop frileuse dès lors
qu'il s'agit de prendre un risque qui
pourtant fait partie du métier
écoutez comment un homme est parvenu à
obtenir à près de 5 millions de francs
de sa banque pour transformer son
château en entreprise
le reportage de geneviève moll et pascal
stelletta lui est de frontenac le maître
du château de palluau sur indre au xviie
siècle serait étonné d'être l'ancêtre
d'une pme car le château est aujourd'hui
une entreprise il faut être économie
gestionnaire financier et avoir une
sacrée imagination pour la gérer
surtout si l'eau n'est comme jean
catinchi le nouveau propriétaire sans un
sou vaillant et qu'on a dû convaincre un
banquier de cautionner un prêt de 500
millions de centimes sur des comptes
prévisionnels
et pourtant la banque de l'orléanais
déry a pris le risque mesuré il est vrai
de jouer la résurrection de taleo fermé
depuis dix ans d'une part le château
lui-même méritait qu'on s'y intéresse
vous l'avez vu le fait que ce château
revivent fait également revivre la
commune de palois et les environs et
donc pour une banque régionale
d'intéressant de réhabiliter une commune
rurale faire revivre une commune rurale
jean caby a conçu son entreprise sous la
forme d'une société jean caby en plus
avaient nous avons fait confiance à
l'oméga
la confiance c'est bien beau mais
ensuite il faut assurer les déchéances
et elles seront de 5 millions de
centimes par mois pendant 15 ans alors
on fait feu de tout bois
on ouvre le château au public et le
châtelain lui même fait faire la visite
on aménage des chambres d'hôtes que l'on
loue à des prix très abordables
mais d'autres concerts soi même le petit
déjeuner et surtout on entraîne dans l'
aventure des partenaires en levant pour
une somme modique les communs du château
résultat a pas lieu aujourd'hui il y à
une crêperie un club d'équitation un
atelier de gravure une fabrique des mots
et un gaffeur de canard en plein berry
le pari de didier urso par exemple 24
ans ancien garde du corps présidentielle
est à bien des égards courageux installé
dans un pays où il ya déjà des personnes
qui font le foie gras vont bien c'est
beaucoup plus dur pour un jeune qui
démarre
si vous voulez si bien il y a moins de
concurrence il ya d'autres risques mais
quel ordre il est bien le faible que ce
soit une région où l'on consomme moins
de confit moins deux fois
il faut se faire connaître déjà il faut
il faut percer percée pour le moment
c'est un espoir tout le monde vit le
châtelain compris avec moins de 3000
francs par mois
alors on avance de multiples activités
pour attirer du monde
car il faudra trente mille visiteurs
pour équilibrer les budgets et pour le
moment il n'y en a que dix mille dans
qu'avant quand vous aurez remboursé
l'emprunt ce serait un châtelain à part
entière qu'est ce que vous allez faire à
ce moment là je crois que je serai de
trouver du successeur que ce soit
peut-être la municipalité que ce soit
des jeunes peut-être lui comme moi
veulent faire quelque chose et je
croirais volontiers ans les jeunes qui
n'ont pas d'argent parce qu'il gens
voudront que peut-être à noeux une
entreprise tout fait
sont ils tous faux sur ce rocher de
palluau non ils entreprennent la rentrée
politique montre le bout de son nez hier
c'est jacques chirac y effectuer son
retour devant les jeunes du rpr anime
aujourd'hui c'est le numéro un du parti
socialiste lionel jospin qui faisait sa
rentrée
l'occasion pour monsieur jospin
d'analyser la situation politique après
le feuilleton du référendum qui a nourri
l'actualité de cet été cette contre
offensive sur le terrain effectivement
du référendum n'était ni une habileté ni
une diversion c'était pas une habileté
parce que je crois qu'il y avait une
interrogation qui avait été créé sur la
question des libertés dans la tête d'un
certain nombre de gens notamment par les
critiques caricaturales de l'opposition
et qu'il était normal que le président
répondre à ces préoccupations et de ce
point de vue là ce n'était pas habile
je pense que ça n'est pas une diversion
aux problèmes économiques et sociaux
parce que l'offensive de la droite sur
ce terrain il en voulait parler devant
le peuple vous avez peur du référendum
était telle que d'une certaine façon ça
empoisonné l'atmosphère et que ça
interdisait au gouvernement de traiter
sereinement les dossiers économiques et
sociaux est loin de faire une diversion
je pense qu'au contraire cela a permis
de déblayer ce terrain d'évacuer cette
question des libertés de montrer que la
droite disait je veux un référendum et
que quand on lui propose
elle n'en veut pas et donc ça permet au
gouvernement
un climat à mon avis plus des passionnés
d'aborder de traiter de continuer à
traiter les grandes questions
économiques et sociales la modernisation
du pays
une interview fort intéressante du
nouveau ministre de l'éducation monsieur
chevènement jean pierre chevènement
répondait aux questions de notre
confrère le monde auquel il a précisé
qu'il souhaitait régler la querelle qui
divise les partisans du public et du
privé et cela en rénovant et en
développement l'école de la république
le ministre s'est toutefois refusé à
confirmer s'il y aurait un projet de loi
chevènement et de quelle manière le
parlement pourrait être saisie une autre
interview elle été confié au figaro par
le président par le président de la cgc
pole mark kelly qui fait état d'un
préjugé favorable à l'égard de laurent
fabius il estime que l'orientation du
nouveau gouvernement est meilleure que
celle de monsieur mauroy monsieur mark
kelly annonce néanmoins qu'il attend
laurent fabius au tournant et que pour
le cg c'est le pouvoir d'achat n'est pas
la priorité mais c'est bien plutôt
l'emploi et l'investissement
et puis une précision à propos de
l'heure de vérité qui devait être
consacrée à laurent fabius le 3
septembre les contraintes de l'emploi du
temps du premier ministre ne permettent
pas de maintenir cette date à laquelle
ils avaient été invités
l'émission est donc reportée au mercredi
5 septembre à 20h30
en conséquence de quoi les programmes
des deux soirées celle du lundi 3 et du
mercredi 5 qui seront permuter dans leur
ensemble
à l'étranger les opérations se
poursuivent en mer rouge pour trouver et
désamorcer les mystérieuses mines qui
ont été mouillés à l'entrée du canal de
suez des opérations jusqu alors
infructueuses jean-marc il use
décidément les eaux du canal et du golfe
de suez garde jalousement leurs secrets
en dépit des moyens ultrasophistiqués
utilisées par les chasseurs ou dragueur
de mines de st marines occidentales
depuis deux mois les résultats ne sont
guère encourageants on l'a repêché des
douzaines de baril de pétrole
un rouleaux de barbelés et même une
cuvette de wc immobilisée par le fonds
explique posément
cet officier britannique pourtant 18
navires de toutes nationalités ont été
légèrement endommagés par les
mystérieuses mines larguées sur un axe
maritime capitale non seulement pour
l'europe et les états unis mais aussi
pour l'urss dont une grande partie de la
flotte de guerre sillonnent l'océan
indien
l'iran puis la libye fortement soupçonné
par l'egypte ont chacun démenti être à
l'origine du minage et personne n'est
totalement convaincu par les
revendications bruyante de
l'organisation terroriste jihad
islamique
le canal de suez et de nouveau
parfaitement navigables mais le mystère
des mines n'est toujours pas éclaircies
et de l'autre côté de l'arabie saoudite
dans le golfe arabo-persique les
pétroliers sont toujours la cible des
aviations irak n iranienne aujourd'hui
c'est un pétrolier panaméen qui était
touché par un missile il aurait été
attaqué par un avion iranien c'est du
moins ce qu'affirme l' agence de presse
du koweït à beyrouth le calme est revenu
après les affrontements du week-end sur
l'ancienne ligne de démarcation entre
l'est et l'ouest de la capitale
libanaise apaisement aussi à tripoli au
nord liban où un accord de pacification
été conclu entre les milices musulmanes
rivales qui se battait depuis une
dizaine de jours
philippe rochât au moment où le premier
ministre libanais annonçait un plan de
paix pour la ville de tripoli au nord
c'est à beyrouth que le nouveau monde a
semé la panique parmi la population
mais c'est seulement mais cet accrochage
avait valeur de test c'est la première
fois en effet qu'on se bat dans beyrouth
depuis la mise en application du plan de
paix pour la capitale qui prévoit le
remplacement des glisses par l'armée
libanaise
l'accrochage s'est produit sur cette
avenue qui coupe en deux la ville d'est
en ouest
tout a commencé dans ce quartier chic de
l'inl est fort très de l'imam sadr et de
l'ayatollah khomeini des miliciens
aurait accroché une patrouille de la 6e
brigade de l'armée libanaise à majorité
chiite également qui contrôlent ces
quartiers les combats se sont étendus
d'autant plus vite que la plupart des
barricades sont à présent démanteler la
5e brigade à majorité chrétienne est
même intervenue croyant à une relance de
la guerre civile
quelques heures plus tard on circule
pourtant à nouveau entre les deux
secteurs de beyrouth
l'important c'est que l'incident ait pu
être étouffée en quelques heures grâce
au réseau de contacts que les hommes
politiques libanais ont mis en place
pour garantir l'application du plan de
sécurité
un test qui pourra donc servir d'exemple
à la ville de tripoli où les combats ont
fait 120 morts en une semaine
toujours l'attention pays basque
espagnol où la maison de vacances d'une
famille française a été incendié dans la
province de gipuzkoa un attentat qui
semble avoir une relation directe avec
l'avis favorable d'extradition de basque
espagnol réfugié en france
un mort et un blessé à nancy c'est le
bilan de l'explosion d'un colis piégé
qui avait été déposé dans un parking
souterrain de la ville
le paquet avait été déposée sur le capot
d'une voiture appartenant à un patron de
bar
françoise champeaux
c'est dans ce parking sous terrain de
nancy qui a explosé vers midi un colis
piégé de fabrication artisanale il était
posée sur le capot d'une voiture garée
au premier sous sol un homme maurice
renault a été tué sur le coup alors
qu'ils se saisissent et du colis âgé
d'une trentaine d'années maurice renault
était un employé du bar de l'est au
moment de l'explosion il était en
compagnie de pierre laurent son patron
propriétaire de la voiture lui
légèrement blessé pierre laurent
surnommé le leclerc de la limonade en
raison des rabais qu'ils pratiquent sur
les consommations étaient sans doute
visé il pourrait s'agir d'un règlement
de comptes
monsieur laurent est actuellement
entendu par le parquet de nancy
sept morts et 23 blessés dans un
incendie à duisbourg en allemagne un
immeuble qui était habité en majorité
par des turcs
c'est l'un des plus graves incendies
survenus depuis la guerre en allemagne
fédérale après les vitesses phénoménales
enregistrés par les concurrents de la
transat la course se termine par un
temps beaucoup plus calme il n'y a plus
guère de vent sur la route voilà qui va
changer un peu la physionomie de cette
course au cours de laquelle les records
ont succédé aux records puisque la
meilleure performance mondiale de
distance à la voile sur 24 heures
cette performance a été remportée par
mike birch sur son navire formule
taguine a parcouru 970 km en l'espace de
24 heures
mais les choses sont un peu différentes
ce soir alors que trois catamarans se
disputent toujours la première place
le résumé de nos envoyés spéciaux 17h15
cet après midi à 100 km au large de
brest
nous découvrons les coqs rouges et
blanches du catamaran royale de philippe
vaquer loïc caradec 1 loïc caradec par
la radio se veut prudent pour des
raisons tactiques
ben tu vois pour un temps bien le
détendue
mais bon ça va toi qu'est ce que vous
avez comme conditions de vent sont pas
très bien compte d'ici au têt un peu dur
d'en parler comme ça au cas où quelqu'un
écoutera quelques années en tant que
vous avez les lanaudois vous l'avez vu
d'autres bateaux à toi non tu es le
premier que nous apercevons tu es le
premier que nous apercevons à toi ok ben
écoute je pense que charente doit être
une quinzaine de milles derrière et puis
que rémy j'aurais plus honorer plusieurs
la côte at war effectivement quelques
minutes plus tard 20 milles derrière
royal c'est charente maritime qui se
présente à l'horizon à la radio philippe
pallu de la barrière sens plutôt
découragés par sa position et le vent
qui tombait de plus en plus
tu as l'air assez pessimiste a l'air
assez pessimiste la course n'est pas
terminée pourtant abandon n'est pas du
tout terminé non mais je veux dire bon
bah on appris
c'est beaucoup quand même à 200 milles
de l'arrivée
tu prévois ton arrivée vers quelle heure
là maintenant si on continue si on
continue comme ça on devra arriver
demain très très tôt mais il est fort
possible qu'une rampe en bois royal
semble donc maintenant en mesure de
l'emporter sauf coup de trafalgar à
l'itie d'une transat express qui aura
duré moins de neuf jours
parmi les favoris il ya bien sûr
charente maritime vous l'avez vu il est
dans le groupe de tête charente maritime
qui avait une arme secrète puisqu'il
avait un allié de poids qui étaient
restés à terre en l'occurrence un
ordinateur utilisé à son profit par une
école d'ingénieurs patrick nash n à eau
navigation assistée par ordinateur c'est
le système utilisé par jean françois
fountaine et pierre follenfant pour
obtenir les meilleures performances
possibles de leur bateau charente
maritime
en plus des données dont disposent tous
les autres concurrents charentes a à son
bord un ordinateur qui enregistre la
position le cas la vitesse du bateau et
celle du vent ces paramètres sont envoyé
deux fois par jour à trois ingénieurs de
l'esn 7 à toulouse qui les traitent par
ordinateur
c'est un programme qui permet d'affiner
les options tactiques je veux dire par
là qu'une analyse météo il ya des gens
qui des médias des égéries terroriste
sigle à pau il ya un navigateur qui la
font aussi des bateaux cd des choses que
l'on sait faire
j'allais dire à la main et le programme
de calcul permet de les affiner
de chercher des options peut-être plus
précise que ce que l'on peut déterminer
par une seule analyse d'une carte zou
parie que vous allez recevoir des
émotions
une fois traitées affiner les
informations sont envoyées à charente
maritime jean françois fountaine le
skipper dispose alors de la meilleure
route possible
on peut se demander alors si ce n'est
pas l'ordinateur qui fait la course à la
place des offres
et ce qui sort là bas c'est trop marcher
le bateau et si le moratoire et sarens
et sen de vitesse ils ont fait des
fouets 3 avec 7 10 c'est pas nous visons
ras bord et qui règle les voiles c'est
lucky luke au marché c'est eux qui
déterminent le cas l'ordinateur avait
prévu la meilleure route charentes a
longtemps mené dans cette transat mais
il n'avait pas prévu ni les erreurs
humaines toujours possible ni les
problèmes de spinaker en charente
maritime a été l'ex c'est peut-être pour
cette cause
royal est en tête avec votre bolide
simonetta la physionomie de ces
dernières heures de course avec une
petite météo marine qui précède le temps
de demain oui parce que nous l'avons
effectivement le vrai problème auquel
seront confrontés les candidats c'est le
vent ou plutôt l'absence de vent en ce
moment sur la manche c'est le calme plat
ou presque jetant un coup d'oeil sur la
photo satellite
l'anticyclone s'étend des açores à leurs
autres centrales cette nuit un flux
perturbé qui pour le moment est situé au
nord du 50e parallèle à l'ouest de la
grande-bretagne va des sens quant à la
situation sur la terre ferme la
perturbation qui touchait aujourd'hui
toute la moitié sud cette perturbation
va sans rouler sur elle même elle finira
par mourir sur place
résultat et nous allons commencer par la
météo marine avec surtout les zones qui
nous intéresse plus particulièrement sur
mon chien c'est manchoise pour le moment
les vents seront variables faibles
secteur nord dominant avec la descente
de la perturbation ils vont passer à
l'ouest ce qui représente évidemment un
avantage pour les bateaux car ils seront
ramenés sur la terre ferme mais trop
problème premièrement ces bons seront
pas très fort force 2 à 3
cela représente à peu près 9 à 18 km
heure donc c'est faible deuxièmement la
prime va se lever et donné une très
mauvaise visibilité
enfin il ya un régime de presse près des
côtes la mère qui est belle pour le
moment deviendra peu agitée alors pour
la situation générale maintenant sur la
terre la perturbation ne touchera pas le
seul résultat sur une grande grande
partie du pays après dissipation des
brouillards épreuve matinaux qui seront
très épais très important ce sera du
bhoutan vraiment un soleil éclatant en
revanche persistant sur toutes les
régions méridionales
des pyrénées aux alpes du sud à la corse
d'un système orageux qui ménagera
toutefois quelques éclaircies dans la
journée le baromètre est tout de même en
hausse
le thermomètre est en hausse sur la
moitié nord de 21 à 24 degrés en
revanche c'est très bas sur la moitié
sud 22 à 26 degrés seulement maximum
demain demain mardi 28 août le soleil se
lèvera 6h01 se couchera 20h41 une
journée à garder le secret ce sera la
sainte hermès patron des aciers c'est
jacques séguin qui vous présentera le
dernier journal vers 23h10 demain
daniel bilalian à 12h45 pour athènes de
midi et je vous retrouverai à 20h
excellente soirée sur antenne 2 à demain